we're live
we're back
at least i think we're live
there we go
what's up everyone rohan dreams a nato
potato marcus what's up
uh
schlock khanna cat tiger lookie thor
walker dead phoenix okay they're too
fast
halo stripe
krug g junior savannah hello everybody
welcome welcome back woof woof cat tiger
is it any good episode hi you know what
someone asked me that today
and i was like i can't remember
like truly like
like truly i i can't remember if it was
like
i can't remember
what episode this is
because there's i know like there are
several episodes with wong in it so i'm
like sitting there like
is this a good one like
i remember
i think four was the better one
of three and and four
just
throwing that up but just to be
perfectly honest i i don't remember much
of episode three
if it's what i think it is
i don't remember much it was
it's been a few weeks since i've seen it
but i don't remember
ever like walking out
i don't remember walking out of the
theater during the premiere thinking
like that sucked
so that's always a good sign right
[Laughter]
let me just check here
why
oh you know what i think i am
on my phone logged into the wrong
youtube channel
i am
but let me check the chat what's up jd
ultra what's going on help porco what's
going on everybody
mr anderson
what is up
okay yeah cool cool
looks like we're good
yeah
everything good
let's just check this
everything seems uh
okay there's a four plus series never
disappoint i
think episode four of she-hulk might be
my favorite
episode one might be my favorite
that was a pretty good one so
we'll have to see i'll have to see him
again okay
okay every single everything seems to be
good
i
think episode
hey sue
you know i
i can't tell why it's so dark i didn't
change anything in my camera settings
yet it's making everything dark
it's just doing it
let me just check everything
i think we are good i think we are good
cool
so what does everybody want from
she-hulk because there's you know
a lot of talk of a lot of cameras
already know daredevil's coming uh we
know wong's in it um a meal we've
already got a meal what is everything
what does everyone want from it yes sue
rocket is right here
kyrie's somewhere i just saw her
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
come on insta it's not that hard is it
are we talking to someone named insta
daredevil daredevil
everyone's just waiting for everyone's
just waiting for daredevil daredevil
daredevil wolverine i don't think we're
getting a wolverine
sorry not to like burst your bubble matt
murdock
good story you know
we'll have to see where the story goes
this
this might be the episode i think where
they kind of tease the larger story
i'm not sure
i i can't differentiate episode three
from episode four i really don't
remember
honestly like i
i really don't i really don't remember
let's check
if i can do this here so yes i'm not in
la i'm at my other home
which i never really disclose where i
live
but i'm not at my place in l.a and when
i'm in la the computer setup i have
there does not let me even
watch
she-hulk even though i don't show any of
it
but when i try to watch it's just a
black screen
it's in korean because i was watching a
korean show
we'll change the audio
english
no sub i know subtitles english
she's probably the only one who
understood what that
what they were saying
cool got it
who is wang lawyer
this is the episode you will find out
i i believe
you'll see wong in this episode
no matter what you'll see wong in this
episode i just can't remember which
episode
if this is if the episode i'm thinking
of is three or four
yes
uh yes i did
dye my hair and it's going to get even
lighter probably in a week
when you bleach your hair you can't just
kind of like
really really breach bleach it it'll
destroy your hair what's up doc zero one
uh what we see saw could fit in she-hulk
totally
totally
um
i'm always like you you guys always ask
like is this this person in this episode
is this person in this episode what
about this and it's like i don't i don't
want to say yes i don't want to say no
because i feel like it's like if i say
yes it's a spoiler right and then if i
say no you're like let down
right so it's like i don't i don't ever
want to answer
i i would just say
um you'll see wong
so
is the post credit mind blowing i've yet
to see a mind-blowing post-credit scene
from she-hulk
so
yes mr anderson and you have a lot more
hair than i do
it is a process so i'm uh
blonde slash brownish it was blue before
it was like a dark blue before because
uh i went to kcon so i dyed it blue so i
had to like
dye it back to like a lighter color and
then this color and uh
yeah
what's the best k-pop band um
you mean group ryan because
or do you actually mean band cause there
are some bands
uh i'm just gonna go group
and that's too hard to answer
but i'll just say
twice
since i am wearing a twice shirt
uh who is megan stallion playing herself
she plays herself
yes uh sorry i could not be here last
week everybody
had a little family thing going on and i
just uh
i didn't have the time
also thank you to elgato because my
studio i wish you all could see it i
will show you all one day but it's so
much better because of them
uh i'm sponsored by them we're partners
so it's uh it's been really cool i can
like control everything just
with this it's like
and then everything oh hi
and then i can like make it brighter or
not
that was really bright
so
really really love all of my oh god of
stuff
mega megan stein's
again i
i don't ever want to say yes or no but
she's not blandstorm
discord promotion i don't know if i have
the link for it let me see if i can find
it
oh
i believe
the link to my discord is in my profile
on youtube
so let's go to the channel
let's go to about and
discord
let's see if this works
do you can i know it i can't put it in
here
here we go
see how that works
link to discord
invite and valid no it doesn't work
let me get one right now let's do let's
get a discord link
for all that want to uh
for all that want to join some
like-minded
people
uh
invite people let's just get
uh invite link
copied
uh
and here you go this should work for the
discord server
oh thank you dr zeigler uh
i it's like blonde in some light and
it's like very light brown in some light
i believe that should be the right
discord server
or the right valve right link okay try
the try the new link try the new link i
know the the one that i put before it
doesn't work try this link now
i would love henry cavill as hyperion
kyle i i would love that
that would be fantastic
yeah ben uh aries pjork uh the thing i
you know i talked i've talked about that
rumor
and um
man
i
i think about like how they would set up
the fantastic four and i think that
they're only two years away now and it
would be cool if they teased them like a
little bit before
yeah hey richard what's up man yeah
have you have you seen episode three
do you have access to that i
i'm having trouble differentiating
episode three and episode four and i
know i really really liked one of them
i'm not saying that one of them's bad
but i i think one of them was my
favorite i think actually episode four
that was my favorite
because i was sitting next to wendy from
the movie couple
and she even said to me too she was like
she was like
i don't like episode four but then i
think she was like at the end she was
like oh wait no it's episode
three
that i liked
less
so i don't know
i know hey jeff likes k-pop
welcome to the cosmic fam welcome
welcome welcome thank you for becoming a
member um
i have started like a k-pop news channel
and like a reaction channel but i'm
keeping it a secret
because i'm trying to grow it
organically so i i i'm like really
trying not to shout it out it's only got
10 subscribers and it's really funny but
i'm having fun like trying to grow it
from nothing and like not use like a
shout out or something like trying to
grow it
like i want to start it from the bottom
and then i want to be here
so um if you guys can find it kudos to
you i will say my name is in like the
title of the channel it's not just my
name but it is in the title and it's
different than my like my cover channel
so
uh walker dead phoenix yes i've heard
that
i've heard that i've heard the rumor of
bryce dallas howard as the mcu's
invisible woman
the new list that i talked about the
other day in one of my videos for the
fantastic four casting i actually
i prefer those uh most of the women on
there
to her there's like two or three on the
list that i was like
but like
sorceronen um
i think she would be fantastic i think
amanda seyfried would be fantastic who
else was it i can't remember the other
one
but
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i really do aiden roth i i really do i
think we are i hope to see
dr jim show up as well
time to hunt for it
uh jeff i'll tell you i don't know if
anybody else really has any interest in
here but my kpop channel it's just
warren x oh i don't even know if you can
find it on youtube to be honest because
i made it less than a week ago like i
made it a few days ago so i don't know
if it shows up like when you search it
but it's literally w-a-r-r-e-n-x-o
so anyone interested in k-pop i'm gonna
do like news and stuff it's pretty much
like i do with the cops make wonder but
it's going to be more focused on
reaction daniel quach you can i see that
you like k-pop too you can find it there
aries yes i i would love doctor doom now
i would love doctor jim now and dietrich
king i
oh
i don't know if you caught my video
where i talked about like the hulk movie
needs to be
like the hulk needs to be the villain he
needs to be bad that's what i want i i
really like that's what i want i want
just a full-on hulk where it's just like
smashing everything like killing people
like
like a hulk you know what i mean like a
hulk a hulk a hulka hulk
hey ricky like blackpink that's awesome
the meyer slept yeah um
killian murphy as doom i'm actually
i'd like that i'm actually okay with
that
uh
i would be pretty cool with that
kingslayer that's a good question do i
feel like
didn't i feel like marvel content is
just a bit disappointing
uh
i don't remember if i ever said that i
don't think i would have said that um
is this
is this
the best phase no
but i don't think this is a bad phase by
any means because to me it gave us loki
one division
moon knight i'm really enjoying she-hulk
i thought miss marvel was a lot of fun
the only things i didn't really like
were what if
um
the falcon in this and the winter
soldier had me in the beginning i
thought it was really good in the
beginning but it kind of fell off for me
i really enjoyed hawkeye i thought it
was a lot of fun
uh i think i'm like a lot of people who
expected a lot of big things and a lot
of big big connections and it didn't
happen right away so
that can be kind of disappointing but
then i think about like the bigger
picture
and i'm okay with it so
um
i don't know if i'm disappointed because
i'm one of the people who enjoyed thor
11 thunder
i i really love that movie i i really do
it's like right up my alley like i'm
very much a
romantic comedy guy like zero shame
admitting that i my two favorite genres
are like the superhero action stuff and
just like action like mission impossible
action and stuff like that i love spy
espionage movies and i l you know and
combine that with like a superhero stuff
and then um i like comedies like
lighthearted stuff
so eleven thunder was right there for me
now don't get me wrong you know i'm a
movie buff and i love movies and i love
like diving into the different aspects
of them and yes there were parts of thor
love and thunder where they should have
like
backed off the jokes a little bit kept
it more you know heartfelt and stuff
like that but uh you know i haven't been
disappointed by phase four
there have been some times where it's a
little lackluster but
overall like i i loved chongqi
that's one of my ultimate favorite
marvel movies now like it's top five for
me i i love that movie um
multiverse of madness was
a bit of a let down in the in the like
aspect of i
thought we were going to get a lot more
cameos than we actually had uh
didn't it so
that was a bit disappointing but i
understood the direction that they were
going hopefully since we're in the
multiversal saga
we're gonna get more cameos pretty soon
so oh you know what mr anderson i need
to uh get
a stopwatch going or what do we could
timer stopwatch what do i stopwatch
there it is
so we can get that up in there
boom
cool cool cool
and then we'll move disney plus to a new
window
uh it's not letting me move it to a new
window will you do this
move tab no window boom
yeah i'm actually like i actually don't
i don't remember much about this at all
like i really don't so i'm uh i'm
excited to actually watch this episode i
feel like i'm
watching it with you guys as if i
haven't watched it yet
excuse me
it keeps like okay there's one there's
one problem i have with disney plus
it's if you go to continue watching
it doesn't let you pick an episode
there's no way to go to like
the place where you pick an episode and
it's so frustrating to me
you have to literally find she-hulk but
you can't find it on the continue
watching and it's so frustrating
is daredev brent abba is daredevil a
born again reboot
yes but
yes and no more towards the the no side
um
it's gonna be a very soft reboot
from what i've heard
but they are going to kind it's going to
basically pick up kind of after
daredevil with a few things kind of
changed
i hope that answers your question in in
the in the complex way that i answered
it
um
yeah walker dead phoenix imagine world
war iii event but in the mcu i mean i'm
waiting for a world war hulk
you know that movie is really really
awesome origin story how do you donate
um you could super chat
um
and any super chats are appreciated and
normal chats are just appreciated um the
chat moves kind of fast sometimes but i
do it but i do try to you know
as you try to get to as many as it can
uh will there be a deadpool and
wolverine fight cameo and she-hulk i
would not hold your breath on that
don't hold your breath on that
uh
where have you been since episode two um
had some family stuff to deal with that
i don't you know want to say
to the public but uh
yeah sometimes just you know life gets
in the way you have to you know deal
with important matters
so sorry i missed last week but we are
here today without spoiling can you tell
us in which episode does the goaded
cameo happen
i haven't seen it yet
so there you go
that's like that's all i can say i
actually don't know
i live the other day devil season so
hyped for next i i missed enchantrex i i
think you meant love and and yeah no
daredevil on netflix was
amazing
will we ever see the living tribunal for
real uh aries i i think there's a big
like cosmic entity
set up movie scene secret wars whatever
it may be i think that's a big thing
that's coming
i think it's a
big thing that's coming uh for y'all
asking about the daredevil cameo i
haven't seen it yet
and i've seen episodes one through four
so
does that answer your question
[Laughter]
it's uh it's he's not in
one through four
yeah enchantrix yeah i'd have to agree
and i really you know i i hope
i hope
the punisher i hope it's john like i
hope they do the same thing that they're
doing for daredevil for him
james larson that's a good question what
was my biggest letdown in the mcu ugh
black widow
um
this is going to sound weird multiverse
of madness but not because it was a bad
film by any means but because i expected
more
from like the cameo and variant side
like
the title is called multiverse of
madness like i feel like we didn't get
that much multiverse or that much
madness like to be completely honest it
should have just been called like
doctor strange and fights the scarlet
witch or something like that you know
what i mean like
the scarlet witch kills the illuminati
something like that that's that's what
it you know
so
yeah but black widow i mean
i feel like it just it like it could
have been so much better and it needed
more love like even like i know we
talked about cgi a lot but like some of
the cgi was like when elena like shoves
the thing into like that engine and like
falls backwards i'm like are you is this
serious is this coming from the billion
dollar studio like did i just see that
i'm like
it was pretty big like down for me
so
yeah the music battle was cool but it
was short-lived and i just wanted like a
bunch of different cameos and a bunch of
different variants and maybe that's just
like the nerd in me that's just getting
like
way too out there and expecting way too
much i think i expected like what i hope
secret wars to be in doctor strange
multiverse of madness and it was really
it's like
they're just focusing on
you know the scarlet witch and doctor
strange
so
mario yeah i just when she shoves the
thing in and like flies back and i'm
just like
this cgi was so bad i couldn't believe
how bad it was but anyways
i'm not trying to crap on black widow i
it's not the best movie but i'm glad
that
scarlett johansson got to do
her movie and i honestly wish we could
get another one and you know someone
give redemption
uh i did see the new poster from disney
d23 it looks like we are in for a
big big treat at d23 hey i've been
saying nova and i saw the you know you
saw the nova core logo
all right it's out apparently thank you
sue
uh
it is out for me mr anderson are we
ready
we're about to get it rolling
all right the episode is 35 minutes long
it is the
it's in the middle the second last
episode was 31 minutes it's 38. we're
going to start this we're going to do it
we're going to do it in five
four
three
two
one
i click play
and i will somehow figure out how to
oh wait hold on
it's still in korean for me
okay now it's in english
that's not it
why can't i figure this out
there we go
here we go here we go here we go
sue
laughing at me
all right one more one more sip of the g
fuels i don't want to be up all night
and now
water with some crystal light in it
dang it is there a mosquito in my room
dang it
that sucks
hey daniel white thanks for super chat
i'm so ready for blade
i'm so ready for my herschel alley
heck yeah hey what's up ritwick
hey leon thank you so much appreciate
that just because
all right here we go
wow my timer is perfectly matched up
i choose not to i remember this episode
long as in this episode
here it is who forced you to escape
[Laughter]
dude daniel white yes yes he is
i'm so stoked for it
oh fourth wall break
dang it
stupid mosquito
remember whose show this actually is
the tattle news
i think i got the mosquito i'm not sure
i love this is like twitter too it's so
funny like this is like
i like how they do this
that smashed
yeah cole
you're a public figure now
what's up tito
the episode is up keep uh
keep refreshing look how big that office
is
this guy sucks
oh this is kind of funny
gross
grass
this guy sucks
i hate this guy oh thanks fc
fc043
this is funny
um
you thought she drove a passat
look who it is
no ah the stupid mosquito
monk's such a good dude
what's up edited version
wong
not again spider-man reference
very messy
this is a great side of wong
strategy b
right ritwick that's what i need
midsize i did you thought she drove a
passat
you're kind of a fool
why are my cats getting the mosquito
rocket get the mosquito get the mosquito
we're not okay
can you guys see rocket let me take a
look good
rockets kind of in the
it was awkward marcus wasn't it
did y'all figure it out
i swear it was a cyber truck spot
ugh
i don't i actually like this guy
you guys know me i like him he's my
favorite so far
out of all the other guys in the show
oh listen to this
oh my gosh
that's how rumors start
oh wasn't that part i thought it was
though interesting
maybe it was last episode i don't
remember dang it
they make a joke about her origin in the
comics
there's your soul mates
huh
you can't already decide
almost the real spam king almost
freaking mosquito
it's gonna be the death of me
metaphysically spiritually
interdimensionally
he does have a place to live
well you know
several pen pals
huh imagine trying to pitch that
my soul mates
my better eighths i love that
oh no
um
let it flow
what's up aaron
kombucha
come on where you at
how do they get this technology
and there he is
dude i'm gonna kill this masculine
this is actually pretty cool
on asgard and now new asgard
thor's inspiration little species
i like this lawyer a lot
it's wong in time
hmm
mm-hmm
oh it's just the part that i think it is
hollywood hookup subscription
oh
no
[Laughter]
yeah that'll help your case
oh this is a cool part
truly lovely
uncontrollably becomes abomination
oh that's funny
it's fine
it's fine yo what's up jake
what's going on dude i didn't see you in
here before
the girls love it
i'm in full control
all right calm down
oh yeah all is closed rip off
enthusiasm
you guys think he's truly changed
i think he's changed i think he's
changed
morbius wins every case
social supreme
[Laughter]
i must depart
[Laughter]
oh this might be the comic origin part
thing i was talking about
you got your powers from a mafia hit go
wrong gone wrong that is how she gets
her powers in the comics
well that's how she gets in the hospital
which requires her to get the blood
transfusion in the comics
hmm
this guy love this guy
i killed him in my head
i like this guy
a whole list of my boys
give you a whole list of my boys
you wanted to know
and then la 11.
pooglyacy
hahahahaha
i like this guy
and jin's great
nice
60 days
there she is there's megan the stallion
no please don't do that
oh
here we go
wait
i don't remember
nice
spiritually of course
you know
be a part of it really look at him look
at him coming up with good ideas
that
tip
she hulk
that's the part i was thinking about
yeah i think this is the part i was
thinking about
that kind of sets up some future stuff
yep here we go
huh
oh wait
the wrecking crew
wrecking crew
i love how they do nothing to her
impenetrable skin
thunderball
nasty green skin
and then there's a post credit
and it's kind of funny
dial it back
and there you go
oh
it says because you watch she-hulk
attorney at law
it's recommending the 2005 fantastic
four for me to watch not a bad
recommendation disney plus not a bad
recommendation but okay that was uh
episode three
what did y'all think
yeah i uh i i heard some of the rumors
you know i heard some people saying that
the post credit was gonna blow people's
minds and i'm just and they're like i
know what it is
and it's just kind of funny
it's not gonna blow people's minds
but you know i'm not the one to sit
there and you know i don't call people
out i let people do their thing
and several people said it and i was
like
i don't think uh i don't think
everyone's gonna feel that way how do i
get rid of this
like this there we go
so who's the boss
who's the boss who we think is the boss
i kind of like kingpin to connect it all
to everything but
i don't think so
what do you guys think who do you think
the boss is
yeah marcus what
do you what did you think oh ricky like
the episode okay cool cool cool
cool
what did you guys think about that
he thinks
jg thinks it's kingpin
what do we all what do you all think
yeah uh jg that's how morbius comes in
yeah i would like it to be kingpin you
know connected to daredevil that's why
he's there as well you know that just
makes the most sense
that's what i thought after watching it
at least
so
when it comes ghost rider mcu and did
young uh
man
the next episode of she-hulk like
big time teases you not like sets up
ghost rider or anything like that but
you know they give us the whole donnie
blaze thing and i'm like donnie blaze
johnny blaze ghostwriter
hey what's up joe thanks for super chat
i'm doing
better
better thank you uh yes sue i agree you
know daredevil is in the show because
the whole kingpin thing
it just makes sense
just makes sense
you recruited the thunderbolts aries
super i would love if it was doom nice
spotter man spider-man um
i don't think it's doom i i think it's
kingpin and i think that's why daredevil
is in the show
yeah
that's who i think the boss is i think i
think it's kingpin i
i hope
because you know the street level team
uh kevin feige has already said is going
to be
um spider-man and it's going to be you
know characters like uh
like she-hulk and my mind's drawing a
blank right now
daredevil they're duh
[Laughter]
yeah so i mean clearly they need like a
a big bad for the street level team the
street level avengers right and i think
that's kingpin
and i think that's what we're seeing
here
is the music megan the stallion i
believe so i don't listen to a lot of
her stuff i just know like her big stuff
so
uh
y'all can tell me in the chat anybody
what if it's luke cage that'd be funny
yeah i think i think this is uh
the kingpin connection and then in the
echo series we'll see more kingpin and
then hopefully a spider-man movie with
kingpin as well and and daredevil
spider-man and daredevil and of course
it's gonna give us you know go into
daredevil reborn and that's the big
kingpin and then it's daredevil and echo
and maybe she-hulk and spiderman all
fighting together
and our own street level avengers film
that's like what i really hope it is but
uh
we'll see we'll see
boss is val but the backer is kingpin
that's uh that's pretty good statement
there uh hunter
i actually like that yeah
ashton i think the boss is galactus
i like where your head's at
yeah i would love a spider-man cameo
um
the writers came out and said that they
weren't allowed to use spider-man and
like at first i was like oh and then i
was like wait a second
are y'all just saying that because there
is a spider-man cameo i'm like hmm
[Music]
that's kind of my thought
but yeah we'll see
uh yeah sorry for everybody who saw you
know some people tweeting on twitter
that the post-credits scene was gonna
blow your minds or whatever it was
uh
i didn't think it would
i didn't think you know
a lot of people were going to be too uh
just like super mind blown about that
but yeah
yeah thanks marcus john
yeah i mean it was megan the stallion
yes it was the it wasn't it so what do
we think of this episode yeah what do we
uh
let's rank it
out of 10
or do we do a plus to f minus
how do we want to do it
but put it wherever you want one out of
ten or
yeah between one to ten or eight plus to
f minus let me hear it let me hear it
uh yes nine episodes i actually think
i i actually think
we
will probably see kingpin
before a post credit of episode nine
i would i would maybe say episode eight
or nine i don't know it depends when
daredevil comes in oh okay okay okay
we're getting a lot of different
responses here
seven eight six four negative ten dang
moro horse hawking reddit three
april three
it was good seven easy now okay hunter
so yeah uh silas five
uh
high a high b okay six point nine gods
here steve i like it i like the 6.9 an s
dang brian
didn't feel like the mcu anymore uh
joseph i you know
here's my thought about this is i think
definitely think that
with all of these disney plush shows
like
the disney plush shows are catering
towards specific audiences
you know i think
you know we have like she-hulk that's
catering to a specific audience uh
miss marvel cater to a specific audience
you know falcon won a soldier like i
think everything is kind of
you know it's not so broad in general
anymore i think that's what the movies
are for but i think with like disney
plus that's what they're trying to do
like
kind of doing that so some of these yeah
they might feel a little bit different
um
this is more of a
it's like a different light-hearted
show you know what i mean like she
breaks the fourth wall and stuff which
like i enjoy but i actually think
they could have utilized her breaking
the fourth wall better
in this because i don't find it that
funny
it's
necessary is that the right word no
it's
cool
cool it's cool
it's cool that she does it
she does in the comics right and that's
why i like i i find it cool um i feel
like it could be
funnier
that's all
yeah abomination made me laugh wong was
uh i like wong's like more lighthearted
side was like send him to the mirror
dimension shadow dimension he's like
okay we'll save sorcery for plan b like
i
i like that i like see and you actually
see even more of that side of wong in
the next episode he's not gone he's not
gone
since the cake was moving that's funny
hurt teague yeah hit fourth ball wall
breaks or meh yeah i mean
yeah
ruchi
d23 poster yeah i think that's on my
agenda for tomorrow
but i got i gotta
do a breakdown of this
the north dimension
world war hulk brother yeah wong was
fantastic and
we have wonder man and wonder woman
call it wow
yeah you know
it's gonna be woke for some people it's
not gonna be work for some people you
know
uh
everyone's gonna have their own opinion
and i'm always i'm always like an
advocate of people
having their own opinions like anytime i
do a review i don't ever want to be like
hey i hated this movie you should hate
it too or like i like this movie you
should like it too i always like people
to form their own opinions
uh where was qr code
where was qr code i'll have to look for
that i bet you i know what they're going
to give you i bet just going to be a
free
she-hulk read
oh guys i'm tough i am uh
i am tired
hey andrew i am glad glad you had fun
glad you were here
who is trying to get she-hulk blood
though i think it's kingpin marcos
hey qr codes on the middle shirt that's
nice
according to trolling experts of
woke-ism i like that
yeah
yeah let's let respectful opinion is
always good like if you think it's well
that's what you think but you don't have
to be like the show everything sucks
because blah blah mosquito
dang it did i kill it
i don't think i killed it
well i will lock it in here in this room
tonight
anyways
yeah i think it's
i think it's
it just doesn't make sense for it to be
anybody else besides kingpin because we
know daredevil's in the show
and echo's coming very soon and then
daredevil's coming very soon
kingpin was in hawkeye there's clearly a
lot of connections here
so
i mean this is the grounded side the
street level side of the mcu right so
it just kind of makes sense the cgi
isn't that bad
or isn't that good sorry it's not
terrible but there are some iffy parts
in it it's just like uh
but hey
you know whatever
you should burn my house down now yeah
because i
yeah um
uh daredevil's not in the next episode
guys sorry i've seen through episode
four and i have not seen daredevil yet
so
um
it's morbius makes all the sense that's
the boss
it's morbius
he's gonna show up in episode nine and
go it's morbid time
yeah
uh the big bad of the multiverse saga i
think is going to be
kang and uh doom
i think those are going to be the two
big bads
yeah
she-hulk got cake though
i love how that's an expression
got cake like i love that
it's funny
yeah yeah that i think we're so used to
like
movie quality cgi
and um
these are disney plush shows that don't
have as big of a budget and it's funny
because they even like
made the cgi better after a lot of fans
complained about it in the trailer in
the trailer that we got so this is kind
of like
better for them it's kind of funny
imagine if we get marvel legends
replicas of stolen asgardians weapons he
cares that'd be kind of cool actually
i'd buy those marvel legends weapons
really what i got storm breaker right
here
and
mjolnir right here and i got iron man's
helmet everything you know
i would buy this for sure
c in morbia stands for cinema ritwik
that's funny
she-hulk twerked
yeah i'm thinking like daredevil shows
up in like episode five that's why they
only gave us episodes one through four
to watch that's typically what happens
like with these episodes is like they
they give us
you know some episodes to watch but they
don't ever give us anything like super
big so we can't spoil it because there
are some you know people out there who
will spoil it
so
oh my gosh i got it
i got it
i killed the mosquito
it actually fell into my keyboard under
my buttons that's
that's something
but i killed it
how did it fall into my okay
yeah it fell literally into my keyboard
into my buttons
but hey i killed the dang mosquito
uh yeah it was wrecking crew in that
episode
yeah
yeah chris's wi-fi guys is just terrible
like and like him and i will play video
games together a lot he can't even play
video games online right now like it's
uh
it's pretty bad but he's uh getting some
new internet pretty soon
and uh should uh
should be back to the
streams later joe thanks for stopping by
uh the leader i guys i just i think the
leader of the boss i i just
i get what people saying you know the
leader but i
i don't see how it's not kingpin
you know
tig thanks well done more thank you
um you know
i
i
i i don't know if we're gonna see ben
grimm i don't know if we'll see the fan
i hope we see like the fantastic four
kind of pop up like before that'd be
really cool but
i'm just wondering if they're just gonna
save it all you know for the movie which
would make sense
you know
so ant-man killed by horn that's who it
was right it wasn't even
how did it go in my mouth
or in my keyboard like this mosquito he
he was he knew he was gonna die so he
decided to take out my keyboard
what does kingpin needs hulk's blood for
well
i you know
i originally thought like
it's thunderbolt ross because you know
he's behind he's probably behind you
know um val and all of that
so i'm thinking like somebody said in
the chat like it could be val and it
could be kingpin who's like the big big
boss um
but if it is you know val then
thunderbolt ross would be a part of that
he needs the hulk's blood turns him in
the red hulk you know like i think that
could you know
there's something there you know so
but yeah
i mean yeah he could also want it for
like some reasons like
the the healing
oh oh yeah teague i was thinking the
same thing
he
so in the comics um he goes blind
because echo shoots him in both of his
eyes
and i'm pretty sure that's what happened
at the end of hawkeye there so yeah
maybe he needs the hulk's blood to heal
you know
huh
uh yeah it's set in uh
was it set in la or is it set in san
diego i can't remember
yeah
yeah so i i think uh
oh sorry not val no
valentina is who i'm talking about who's
setting up the thunderbolt sorry sue no
uh that mosquito was definitely mephisto
for sure
for sure
yeah morpheus more like more bs
yeah i think uh
maybe kingpin does need the blood
to cure him i think
that we're onto something here
but it could be thunderbolt ross and
that could be how we get red hulk but i
the only thing is is like i don't know
if they're gonna go that route anymore
since william hurt passed away
i don't know if they're gonna do it that
way
san francisco that's what i meant
arizona not san diego i think it's in
san francisco
i'm getting like phantom mosquito bites
now i like i i think the mosquitoes are
here even though i know i killed it i
saw the dead body
uh jeff likes k-pop uh maybe um
he could
i think i think that it's more along the
lines of like there's going to be
i mean it's like what you yes what you
said but i don't think it's all disney
plus shows i think it's like the street
level disney plus shows kingpin is going
to be the boss one
yeah
uh worst episode do i think um
i'll say that episode one and four are
my favorites
so
maybe it's the worst one maybe the
second one was i'm not sure i'm not sure
so all right guys i'm super as i yawn of
course i'm super tired
oh
oof
and i gotta get up actually at a decent
time tomorrow and it's already almost 2
am here so um we're gonna wrap this up
um i saw somebody else are there any
cameos other than daredevil i've only
seen through episode four there's nine
episodes so i i really don't know
you know i've heard rumors but rumors
are rumors sometimes they're true a lot
of times they're not so we'll have to
wait and see
um
the time length yeah it's a typical
it's a typical
short disney plus but it's like a comedy
you know and everything oh couple of
super chats thanks so much blonsky lied
the government didn't turn him
daniel super chat
uh you know
i always want i actually i'm like is
this rhett conning you know like
we'll have to wait and see on that i
think there's more to this story
jeff what's up thanks for another super
chat always coming to clutch with those
love the show to get to see daredevil
next episode glad you're back live
stream hope families okay thanks so much
for that i appreciate that um
i will say daredevil's not in the next
episode and i've only seen up to the
next episode i've only seen the first
four so maybe he's in five
dude
that's not a mosquito that's just a fly
or something okay
um yeah maybe he's in
maybe he's in the fifth one but he's on
the in the fourth one
kenneth estrella thanks for super chat
daniel d lewis taking william hurt's
place hmm
betty ross cameo yeah i uh
i don't know
you know um
i don't know
i hope they recast and like that is
absolutely no disrespect to william hurt
at all but i think like the character is
important like i really do i really do
well sue i gotta get to sleep then i
gotta wake up and do the breakdown so
so yeah um thank you all for the super
chats but let's cut the super chats now
because i'm about to get off i don't
want to miss any although i do
appreciate them i appreciate everybody
watching everybody chatting everybody
super chatting um as you all know i
really really appreciate the support um
it's what keeps me going when this gets
hard sometimes so thank you all so much
really do mean that really you love you
all um
so yeah i'm gonna go to sleep i hope you
all uh go to sleep too unless you know
it's not uh you know really really late
at night for you like sue
so um
yeah midnight was good but yeah all
right guys i'm going to go to bed now
look out for my breakdown tomorrow and
possibly another video depending on how
much sleep i actually uh
can get tonight you can check out mr
anderson's channel um he put the link in
the comments somewhere i saw it as there
sometime uh
check him out also of course thanks mr
anderson another great uh
live stream you're awesome
moderator and thank you to everybody for
stopping by
and
i'm so tired that i can't really
determine what i want to say but i just
want to say love you all and i'll catch
you guys next time